we have some what i would consider
potentially good news coming in the
ukraine russia situation now in this
particular case what we consider good
news really depends on one's perspective
in the entire uh conflict and as many of
you know uh at odds with what
some people believe uh both people in my
audience and other people who comment on
uh what's going on uh around the world
i do not see
ukraine as the aggressor
i do not see the responsibility of
solving the conflict to be joe biden's i
don't see the possibility of ukraine
joining nato as a legitimate quote
aggression on the basis of which
vladimir putin
could
um
mass troops at the border threaten
aggression and if it came to it
actually execute aggression uh into
ukraine that's not my perspective i see
that the aggressor massing the troops
is the aggressor and to me that's
calling things what they are now i know
many of you have emailed me and said
well no you know promises were made that
uh
nato wouldn't expand and it would no
that that that is a false notion and we
went through that yesterday um
and uh in the context of calling things
what they are there are now some
statements being made uh by russian
authorities which if true if true signal
that this is not going to lead to an
invasion of ukraine which i consider a
good thing
uh cnn reporting russia announced that
some of its troops would return to base
after completing recent drills but
stressed that major military exercises
would continue ukraine has responded
understandably skeptically saying we'll
believe it when we see it following the
announcement the u.s ambassador to nato
said the u.s will have to verify claims
of a potential move towards
de-escalation by russia meanwhile
last-ditch western diplomatic efforts
continue with german chancellor olaf
schultz in moscow to meet russian
president vladimir putin late monday the
kremlin told cnn putin is willing to
negotiate saying the ukraine crisis was
only one part of russia's larger
security concerns now it can't be
ignored that part of the security
concerns being claimed by russia strike
me as very insincere
because when you consider the the broad
claim
that um
nato involvement in ukraine is a direct
threat to russia and signals further
this that or the other thing
the truth is that there have been other
countries in the area including latvia
where there has been no such escalation
there has been a presence a western
presence and there has been no such
escalation and so it's sort of a an
alleged slippery slope without really a
reason to believe that that's going to
happen but listen i mean if if it's if
putin is genuine that he's willing to
negotiate and and back down i i think
it's a good thing and of course the
question with putin always is
is this 4d chess you know with with
trump uh we would say well when he when
he drew the
using a sharpie on the hurricane map or
uh when he had that insane call with
ukraine or when he was flushing
documents down the toilet you know there
was this idea it's 4d chess with trump
he's got something planned and very
carefully crafted no he didn't he was a
buffoon there was no 40 chests being
played played things were what they
appeared to be
putin is much smarter than trump it's
just the reality and so with putin there
is the consideration as to is this 4d
chess and from the beginning there was
the question of is putin's real
intention to invade or not and if not
what is the underlying intention here uh
the associated press also reporting
russia ready to discuss
confidence-building measures
and that article reads russian president
putin said tuesday moscow is ready for
talks with the u.s and nato on limits
for missile deployments and military
transparency in a new sign of easing
east east-west tensions the statement
came after russia announced it is
pulling back some troops from exercises
that raised fears of a potential
invasion of ukraine you know the other
thing i i have a problem with in this
entire um uh context
are
if you've been watching my show for some
time um you are i'm sure aware
that when someone like me
says hey
this thing russia's doing isn't good
hey this thing china's doing isn't good
this thing venezuela is doing isn't good
there is a contingent of the left that
hears that and says david
you imperialist bastard
looking to send troops i don't know why
i do the alex jones voice but saying you
you want the u.s troops involved
everywhere and you want biden to send it
no i don't
no i don't that that's not at all what i
want and in fact there's really no
incentive as many of you know
i want stability
i want calm
even if it's out of selfish
desires
for
a steady economy
a calm and tranquil stock market part of
the insanity with three consecutive big
days of market declines etc part of it
has been
the threat of escalation in ukraine
russia why why would i want that i don't
so
not only is it not
and i'm speaking now not just about
myself but others on the left who point
out hey we can agree that putin is the
one threatening aggression here
while still not wanting this to escalate
and not wanting american troops involved
we can walk and chew gum at the same
time and immediately as of right now
this might change but the stock market
is reacting very favorably to what
seemed to be decreased tensions in the
region so there is no political reason
that i would want american imperialism
and sending troops are in escalation i
don't want it and even if you ignore the
fact that it doesn't align with my
politics which have been
defaulting to non-intervention in most
cases for for the united states both
politically and militarily and that
applies to cuba venezuela russia etc uh
an unfettered record of such positions
um just out of selfish economic concerns
i would also not be incentivized to want
those things so
that is my perspective on this
and uh those who continue to try to
attribute
some kind of bloodthirsty hegemonic
imperialism to me um it's it's just not
based in anything i've ever said i think
that's the important thing let's see
what happens in the next 24 hours
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our
longtime sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman